we're going to be doing this a little
differently uh-huh i believe that the
developer should
definitely create a system where one
person should stay in the caravan at all
times
to monitor the situation monitor
people's sanity and
like keep tabs on everything through the
cameras and yada yada and all that kind
of stuff
sure so um this will be our first
professional job together
is professional the hardest yep oh new
things we have head mounted cameras
so that way whoever's monitoring can see
the two people wearing the head mounted
cameras walking around at all times or
whatever
good i like how mark and i are slowly
backing away from loud wade
have you guys been to the asylum yeah we
did the asylum yeah we did that that was
the last thing we did last time we
played yeah yeah cool do we have good
flashlights or crap flashlights no
that's
a good strong flashlight yeah we're good
we're good to go
we're loaded to the tits hello
hello okay so i'll i can take first
watch
in the in the trailer are you sure
because i've played this a bunch if you
guys want to go and explore and get the
experience
sure you can do that does the head
mounted cam take
an inventory slot no actually does not
oh okay well that's good
what is the weird dish thing that's the
parabolic microphone it's actually
pretty cool somebody grabbed the gray
camera if you could the gray camera on
the left there
okay i gotta get a photo of the ghost
find evidence with an emf reader and
find a room below 10 degrees celsius
with a thermometer all right well i've
got emf and spirit box
so mark i don't know if we need the
microphone we might we we might want the
thermometer i think
oh but i i really want the big
microphone but i'll give it up for you
guys
all right enough talking let's get
walking good luck
it's for nerds wait are we supposed to
be together or not together
you can go either way but the place is
big so you might want to split up to at
least locate it
all right i'll go right take that side
i'll take this side yeah sounds good
that's the ticket good luck boys thank
you papa
i'm hearing something crawling through
the walls or something
that's not good if your light starts
flashing and [ __ ] gets scary get into a
room
hide close the door all right understood
how are those cams looking big papa
overwatch
i haven't looked at your cams i've been
cycling through the room slowly looking
for orbs or something to see if i can
try to narrow down where it might be
uh orbs show up on the the overhead cams
yeah yeah they can show up on any kind
of cam
no temperature readings yet no emf
anywhere yet no ghost activity yet
either
it's hiding are you here
uh was that someone laughing
[Music]
so mark the room you were in there's a
staircase not too far from you it could
have been like
below you in the basement back there but
go ahead and do your loop first and see
roger your sanities are both down to 65
give or take 65. does that happen
because we're in the dark or what
it could be because i don't fully know
could be the dark could be ghost
activity i think being in the darkness
definitely does affect it
all right well when one of us goes below
like 30 we'll rotate out for the
the trailer all right i got nothing on
my loop i'm gonna head downstairs
sanitizer at 55 door
is open at the end of this hallway with
a light on hell yeah brother
definitely it was not over there i'm
just going down for the first time wait
do you see what i'm talking about
yeah there's a camera in the distance
that could definitely see it i think i'm
watching your perspective now are you
approaching a flipped over bed or
something no that's
oh yes yes yes i am okay i've got your
camera
okay just check them out my flight just
flickered my light just flickered
oh i just got a a sudden drop in
temperature but it went right back up
i'm coming your way yeah it's definitely
i think you're getting close if you're
getting temperature drops you're getting
close
yeah i think it's in to captioning not
i hear you available to me come to me
let me know if temperature gets below
zero celsius
not yet uh we're at five the light as
soon as i entered just turned off
activity is a zero sanity is at 45
okay so that's the room yeah this is the
room it's definitely four degrees in
here
it's i think it's in here let me let me
emf this [ __ ] and spirit box a little
bit
there any dumbass ghosts hanging around
all right not the detector there but
all right okay so you're sure that if i
say things it won't get mad
right that's the ghost presence so if
you guys might be like in the room next
to it or something or it might be the
right room it's hard to tell
well it's definitely cold in here it's
definitely i was just wondering
if i definitely don't say that the ghost
is a big dumb stupid idiot for dying
like a dumb
then you know that's not gonna get me in
trouble right no that's probably fine
that's probably safe
okay yeah we're getting a whole lot of
nothing besides the temperature
emf's one of the objectives so emf
should at least go up to two
oh my god we're not getting any ems
the light keeps turning off in here
vanities down to 35 for both of you
yup feel that all right it's gotta be
it's gotta be in that room
bathrooms i guess i mean it seems like
it yeah it could be upstairs in that
room
no it's just turned off again if the
light just keeps turning on and off is
that a thing
moving physical objects is that a thing
yeah every time you say that
the activity has spiked but it's not
going any higher than a four
all right well maybe we should instigate
mark what's the name ruth
wilson ruth wilson
think it's working i'd be mad
is that you playing with your lights
with you big dummy yeah i'm doing that
okay ruth wilson oh
that wasn't me yeah i know i know
uh-oh
okay yeah we'll just wait here
are you here with us okay i think we
need like the journal or something can
you have anything on our head cams for
orbs sorry yeah wait i was talking about
it yeah do you have anything uh on camp
for the herbs
oh my god mark run run yeah you run it's
right behind you
run we're running we're running around
we're running we're running oh my god
i'm just gonna close the store i'm gonna
hide in the room that i was in
oh my god oh my god
wade can't hear us mark wade can't hear
us that's fine i'm hiding in this room
wait if you can hear us let us know we
just had to encounter
mark my flashlight's still flashing i'm
in trouble yeah okay just get in the
place and hide
i'm hiding okay good
ah are you okay you okay i'm okay
my flashlight's still just going ham
wade can you hear us
yeah you guys back you good yeah we're
both alive we're both fine
okay did you see it yes i saw it it was
an old lady
it had a scythe if you get another
chance take a picture of it
yeah okay sure thing boss it's either a
gin
or an oni i think mark and i should come
back to the truck
and check in come back to the truck
all right we're coming back let's get
out of here yeah let's get out of here
oh god oh we're in trouble
this is my room we're hiding together
it's fine oh my god it's fine
[Music]
can it hear us if we talk i don't know i
don't know
i i don't like sitting in the dark i
hate this that's fine if it gets you
i'll shine my light and i'll take a
picture
let me get your terror that's a good
pick
you're all good uh overwatch overwatch
can you hear us
no big bird big bird please come in
that's fine this is fine what if we just
go for it
wait can you hear us waking yours yeah
maybe i'll put here you guys it just
went back down to the
encounter oh yeah another encounter
we're trying to get out now
yeah how's our sanity looking fast work
left stairs
fast fast fast ah this is my maximum
sprint speed
no come on man i literally am pumping my
legs as hard as i pump
i think to the left here is where we
want to go yeah you guys are fine yeah
go down the hallway make a right and the
entrance will be on your left
yo yo yo i think we're going to be all
right i think we're going to be i think
we're both going to get out
and it's going to be fine we're both
going to survive
we're going to survive
we're going to live we're going to be
fine
nothing bad will happen please don't why
doing that
i'm not doing that you were doing that
hey
that's not good uh okay wade you are on
your own right you got this
how do i take it yeah sure i got the
book so i guess i'll go and try to drop
it off what did it mean
it was either a oni or a what oni or a
gin so either
it's either ghost orbs or it's the ghost
writing well you would have seen ghosts
we have temp
didn't we have thought
yeah go here go take the camera weight
and you go take a picture of it okay
i'll go with him i'll go with him all
right i'll
uh i'll run cams mark i believe the
cameras are 12
15 and then 16 17 and 18 are us roger
that
can i just close this door i just want
to close this door you know i
just want to close this door okay good
all right just checking in seeing how
you doing you guys hungry
okay i'm seeing you on the cams i'm
trying to keep an eye on you guys
uh oh my god i heard something
here
[Music]
guys checking in
activities out of 10
guys
okay they're hiding over there they're
hiding basically just at the bottom of
the stairwell
uh check-in check-in check-in hello
hello
oh that's me hello hello hello
oh my god okay hello are you there
hey can you hear us we good yeah yeah
man activity went up i tried to warn you
but it was already out by the time
yeah it's hard to get warning in dude i
heard a door lock
out here like i literally heard the door
close and locked
yeah all the doors like yeah the doors
out all locked that happened
fun good yeah great uh other than that
you guys seem to be no worse for wear so
congratulations you made it
uh yeah you're approaching the room it's
the room with the bed that's definitely
it it locked again
oh my god that ghost is so mad at them
what if i actually can get like
anything with this screaming i'm just
gonna hear screaming
oh nothing okay good nothing they're
probably fine
check the door what do you mean check
the door of course the door's gonna be
locked i can't go in it's locked
hello oh this is a long one oh it is
mad are you back in
uh we're back we're fine okay good
bad yeah that ghost is mad mark do you
know which room it was
it was the one with the bed it was the
room with the bed i was just about to
tell you that mark
we're going to turn off our lights look
for ghost orbs on one of our cameras
rods 17 or 18. i'm already on it
uh oh you guys are in trouble
it's right outside the door oh my god oh
my god
oh my god
oh no he's dead oh my god
are you there hello where is dead yeah
way it's dead i'm just gonna try and get
out i got a picture of wade i'm just
running my way out right now yeah
you did not get a picture of the ghost
but don't even worry about just get out
there i think we know what it is
oh wait did it ghost right [ __ ] i should
have looked it's probably fine let's
assume that it is because there's no way
that it was the other thing because i
would have seen a ghost orb
yeah just straight through there and
then uh to the right oh no
oh no oh my god ron oh my god run
oh my god bob ron please
uh bob you're yeah hide bob if you can
hear me just stay safe you're so close
to the exit
it's almost over
probably about five seconds
and it's over hello hello can you hear
me i hear you i'm coming okay you go
just go
go go go go you're looking good you're
looking good
you're looking so good come on in come
home
how could you tell it was almost over uh
because it it usually goes for a certain
duration of time
on this total activity meter it never it
never much goes longer than the full
length of the bar
okay i'm gonna write in my journal that
it was um that no ghost orbs
let's just say it was ghostwriting let's
let's take a guess yeah i feel like we
got a guess
okay closing up the door so recipes wade
sorry i got a picture of you wade don't
worry we got your insurance money buddy
yeah
oh do you need to get a picture of the
dead body to get insurance
i yeah i believe that you did get a
picture of the ghost
oh my god it was noni we did it yeah but
you i i saw a picture of the ghost
hi wade hey guys hey wait did i get you
your insurance money
sadly there's no insurance on
professional difficulty ah
i tried really hard to get a picture
right before i died there's a picture
right here i see it
it didn't give us the objective money
but uh we got it in our hearts
look at my [ __ ] body yeah yeah you
died real weird i died putting my dick
through a hole in the wall
the strangest thing was i saw it on
cameras outside of the hallway that you
were i didn't know that it would get you
through the wall so maybe stay away from
the walls that are adjacent to the
hallway
no we were in it and then it walked into
the room
okay i saw it get weighed okay cool all
right gotcha
yeah yeah probably hiding in the spawn
room yeah
[Laughter]
i do want to try the parabolic
microphone i i just want to see
like that i think that's very useful if
it if it's the way i think it is
it's good for tracking i used it once in
a smaller place and you could i could
both basically tracking the ghost
walking around but like it doesn't help
with anything else
that's fair oh also mark uh while i was
cowering in fear wade and my chat uh
were like
don't talk he can hear you oh okay so
apparently we got
really lucky that we were just talking
up the store while we were hiding
so you can combine a regular video
camera with a tripod i did buy a tripod
and we can set them up wherever we kind
of want to for that because we're doing
a small house
so there won't really be any good inside
cameras by default but we can set up one
once we find the ghost room okay that's
fine i think that i was really just
using the head man in camera
just to like see pov yeah yeah that's
typically fine so there's gonna be much
smaller location but it's still
professional difficulty okay sounds good
i'm ready
let's do it carol jones is our ghost we
can all be in the room if need be
we need to set up a motion sensor oh
motion sensor is the
dark gray one with the red and green
light over here okay i'm going to start
on overwatch this time i'm going to not
be able to photo of the ghost
okay i've got emf and uv light
uh what else do we need we need to get a
camera motion sensor and thermometer
maybe mark cause you're okay
camera motion sensor was a green one no
no this dark gray one there's two of
them side by side
oh yeah the red light one gotcha okay
got it and then the yellow thermometer
uh well i mean i only got so many hands
yeah i mean
if if it gets cold enough that we
actually detected we'd breathe anyway so
i think that's fine moving out daddy and
the bus
watching over two kitties come back to
me thank you big daddy on the bus
laugh at our call signs we agreed upon
these calls daddy and the bus
going in the house now confirmed what
was my call sign
kitty number two uh my kitty number one
you're actually kidding number three
don't talk about the first kitties
all right fair enough big daddy in the
bus are there any cameras on this
property
uh big daddy on the bus there is a porch
camera that's it
big big big big nothing okay
checking the basement uh level five
activity right now level five
that's a little early big daddy in the
bus i'm just telling you what the
numbers say don't judge big daddy in the
bus
wouldn't dream of it i found a bone i'm
taking a picture
i still don't know if we're supposed to
fill them up and let the ghost dirtier
if the ghost turns it on i've gotten
mixed reports on that too
one time i filled it up in one of the
farmhouses and it turned dirty and
that's the only information i've ever
learned
also level three level four ghost
activity persistent ghost activity
roger that on the ghost activity i'm not
seeing anything i'm gonna go upstairs
but i don't really have anything to
detect it
ghost's name is carol jones if you're
looking to instigate
uh big daddy in the bus i got a ball
did you turn the water on up here i
turned the water on downstairs but i'm
more worried about this ball
here uh confirmed ball sighting unclear
what this means
i would place that motion right on this
wall
okay because i think it's movement i
think it's around here somewhere
ghost activity down to zero my children
sorry kitties
mf3 in this bedroom coming do you see
breath in here oh brent freezing
temperatures freezing temperatures
roger that moving the scanner in here
i threw it objective crossed off the
ghost wasn't the motor
just roger that coming back to the truck
to switch out some stuff
okay i'm gonna grab the journal and like
the spirit box i think
uh sandy's at thirty percent kitty
number three
i'll call when you get down below maybe
20 and then we'll rotate roger
i'm gonna set down the ghost journal and
then uh look for fingerprints
do you need the spirit box to get it
writing no spirit box would be a
separate thing to confirm talking
uh big daddy on the bus what was the
name of this ghost
lights flashing lights are flashing hide
no i'm going for that closet oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god
so
oh there you are yeah oh man it was
walking outside this closet back and
forth
both sanity's below zero
all right coming outside retreating
coming into the warm embrace of big
daddy on the bus we are outside
we're coming oh my god i don't believe
you survived
yeah me neither it literally wait you
were going for that closet i'm like
don't you dare
[ __ ] there i was going into the
hallway as far as i could
okay it literally walked right by the
closet i heard the footsteps and it's
just going for you i'm like oh wade's
dead he's so dead
he's dead he's a dead man you weren't
moving at all right that was it
oh yeah that was it i was not moving so
do we have evidence confirmed other than
freezing temperature
uh no not at the moment emf only got to
a three i didn't double check for ghost
running because of our sanity
i didn't see anything with uv yet so
we've we haven't spirit boxed in there
either have we done nobody could you
know we need spirit box
somebody could take the tripod and the
camera and set it up look we could look
for ghost orbs
i'm just gonna set the camera i'm not
going to take the photo camera though
then because i need to take the spirit
box
yeah uh good luck my sandy's so long to
stay in the truck
they're going to take some drugs to take
some drugs
we'd take a drug if you use the drugs it
doesn't actually count as using them you
still get them back as long as you're
alive so like it doesn't hurt wow
unlimited drugs all right well have fun
out there kiddies
all right let's do this all right fun
bye all right uh changing code name to
big daddy in the house
uh wait you're still kidding number two
ghost activity at ten
oh no oh no
guys oh no oh god
oh [ __ ] oh my god
where'd he go okay he's a lot he's no
okay he's fine oh my god i thought he
died his his little
icon blipped out of existence i thought
he was done
okay all right big daddy in the house
oh my god i can't believe i survived i
thought you were
dead actually i'm good i'm good yeah i
hid in the middle of the living room
because i couldn't find another room to
go into
no ghost riding mark i might set your
camera up so you can look for
roger how's that camera angle should be
yeah that's good i see the whole room
i'm gonna keep an eye on that one
specifically
i see your breath hanging in the air oh
my god it's in the room whoever's in
that room
oh my god it's in the room
was that a ghost or something just went
whoosh are you there guys
hello yeah oh my god are we okay yeah it
was literally like i looked in the
camera like yeah great view and then the
ghost was walking right in front of it
you got ghost orbs confirmed by the way
ghost orbs are the little floating like
moats of dust right
yeah yeah anything sparkly and floating
yeah that was ghost storage print
so we're down to phantom mare and yuri
ghost writing spirit box emf5
still no ghost writing we had some emf
right do we have an emf with it
uh do the spirit box that's the one you
haven't done yet i'm spirit boxing i'm
getting nothing in the room right
i'm gonna come back for emf this is an
elusive son of a [ __ ] wade by the way
your
your sanity is so it's rock bottom
oh my oh my god hi it's back at 10
i hope bob's hiding okay
oh yeah he's uh hi
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no oh
he's dead all right uh i don't know if
that was spirit box confirmed or uh what
oh [ __ ] yeah we don't know well i've got
the emf if you want to go in in spirit
box we're gonna have to go back in take
those sanity
oh my god yeah okay
yeah okay i'll i'll go and i guess it's
on my turn
i'm taking a [ __ ] crucifix what do we
need what do we need
the three things we need to check are
emf which i've got uh ghost writing
which is already in there spirit box
which bob had on
one right there yeah i'll go get his
just to have it
all right let's grab a crucifix maybe i
did i i did
i got it all right yeah let's go
oh my god
why are you not talking to me wade emf's
a four not a five
that's wonderful oh my god it really
messed with his body this is some ring
level [ __ ]
i'm gonna toss this in here oh my god
the crucifix no my god
i can't pick it up i can't pick up his
box are you here give us a sign
oh okay there we go we got it let's get
out of here
you not talking to me he's really
covering wade i'm here
i don't want to press v why not because
i'm scared
that's fine i'm out of here we i got the
spirit box we're good
wait
[Music]
what about my oh my god wait i thought
you were dead you were behind me and oh
you [ __ ] i went to check for dirty
water
oh my god i literally was walked out the
front door turned around and you were
not there
i was looking for dirty water oh my god
you dropped the crucifix in the room
it's probably safe for a minute you want
to go back
you want to go back you want to go back
no no i didn't think so
it's a mare it's a female horse don't
want to go back yeah i don't want to go
back either
so we're an ie if you want to go back
you go back but i'm not going to go back
this is the source of all nightmares
making it the most powerful in the dark
ah we didn't turn on a single
light weakness turning lights on around
the mirror will lower its chance at the
top
mom i hope
all right hey thanks for not getting my
insurance
by the way well i thought there wasn't
any insurance unprofessional
oh [ __ ] that's right yeah we're not
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] uh whatever it left your body
messed up man your body was twisted all
up
my flashlight started going and i was
like [ __ ] and i dove for the closet
and crouched in the corner and all i
hear is thump
thump thump
[Laughter]
yeah is there anything i should get
because i got 250 bucks and i got
nothing in my name
you could probably keep saving because
if i die we're going to buy a whole
bunch of [ __ ]
well i mean oh my gosh i'll just add in
my strong flashlight
money i spent 500 on stuff these head
mounted cameras are like 60 each
yeah a lot okay all right
don't die i'm the most important numbers
oh yeah
you are the most important if there's
anything i've learned about this game
that low-level people with no money or
nothing
they're useless thank you i'm glad you
learned your lesson all right i'm ready
daddy-o is it less creepy if it's
daddy-o versus daddy or is that all
pretty creepy i think it's less creepy
with daddy-o but we could make it creepy
we're good at that daddy oh oh
oh my god it did the daddy oh we
immediately won
[Laughter]
motion sensor thermometer smudge sticks
are our objectives
i don't think we should do smudge sticks
right away though we should hold off on
those
thermometer okay thermometer
who's wait i think it's your turn
to start on you guys need to be alone
we're looking for mark
thompson mark thompson all right we'll
just have to split up all right
uh i can grab the emf as well all right
i got it
what should i take weight should i bring
like a camera or something
um i would say if one of you has the
thermometer the other should bring emf
just because those are helpful for we
got those emf and spirit box i got those
a video camera to set up might be good
to look for ghost awards if i find
anything with perometer i'll set you up
a video cam
okay you're looking for mark thompson
mark thompson got it
keep saying it loud and proud bye
make sure you give us all silly call
signs yeah yes please
he's just i mean okay he doesn't even
put any effort into it
should have gone with big daddy when you
had the chance all right i'll pick left
you take break
any temperature reading is that good you
got to turn it on we'll make it
father big father i mean okay
yeah what am i what am i trying a little
harder i mean debating a lot of what he
is
i'll be uh maybe i'll be big wonka or
i'll be
willy willy smalls don't be really small
okay well i guess all right i guess
we're going with willie smalls
yeah willie smalls number one and lumpa
ii
that makes me laugh i can't i can't deny
it can't deny it
all right whatever oh don't be grumpy
mark don't be grouping morgan i'll be
grumpy if i want to be grumpy you guys
be grumpy it's okay
[Music]
that's not funny
i'm not singing the song oh no sure
that's
that's a ghost thing yeah it must be
must have been you know
yeah you're some kind of idiot
it's not hurtful if it's the truth
sanity is
67 yeah cause bob's driving me crazy
are you referring to lumpa ii yeah
loompa ii is driving
crazy
yeah you're really under utilizing the
handles that you spent so much time and
effort
willie smalls will attempt to do better
over
i'm roger
you you're making fun of me [ __ ]
come in is that uh lumpa 2 i'm talking
to myself like a sane person
hey what was the name of the ghost why
don't you tell
willy me definitely not hey daddy willy
pants what's the name of the ghost
our ghost is mark thompson
you weren't even close i think i'm
actually coming over to where you are
yeah you are
why constantly no need one are you on
stairs right now or is that lumpa
we're together we're we're next to the
stairs i just went up the stairs yeah
okay so lupitu you're 17. okay so i'm
beginning to think that it was probably
downstairs where bob was because i was
i had my emf out the whole time and i
was getting nothing copy that i would
check
then downstairs i think it might have
been the right side well left side if
you're entering the school
i had no cold spots but i uh
it could be down there i was chilly but
not cold you know
like like a like a light hoodie but not
like a full-on
sweater roger i know you're saying roger
but you let go of the button kind of
fast and it just sounds like you go
i mean if you are saying raw i want to
understand why i'm with you i support
you fully completely but
you know i just want to let you know how
it's coming across you know
i hope the ghost shows up and kills me i
just i want to say that out loud
i want to say its name a little bit i'll
probably indulge you
oblige you even compromise you
mark thompson mark thompson
i'm beginning to think this uh ghost was
a bogus call
i i don't think there's anything in here
could be that your sanities are both at
well once again i blame lumpa too
boss i'm not the idiot with the name
boompo one
yeah as if loompa two is any better
who's loompa won then
everybody knows what lumpa2 means and
what it's referencing it's a very clever
name
yeah well if it's so clever why don't
you explain it and lupa please get along
no no copy that sanity is down to 25
this is willie smalls is down to 25
roger can you say that activity is up to
a two
activity
mark thompson there's no ghost in here
there's no ghost here i think he's
actually
i'm just kind of happy to hear you boys
agreeing on something
yeah there's a whole lot of nothing
happening the time i'm seeing activities
whenever you boys are down like the
bottom
left side which is bottom right on the
map but if you're coming into the school
bottom left
i'm currently uh bottom left side i
don't see anything
you're heading up toward the top and uh
bob is also kind of like top middle now
according to the map mark's at the end
of that hallway
oompa-1 is at the end of that hallway
[Music]
you guys okay yep all good
one
oh no just wanted to see what if he
would gloat over my death
i'm fine i would be so deeply upset if
you died what are you talking about
yeah you sounded with your own zero
sanity
sanity is overrated yeah i don't i
still have no idea where this uh where
this uh mark
thompson is i saw a heavy flash
oh i said he's spiking get out get out
get out okay getting out
okay getting out mark thompson
oh my god oh no are you inside of me no
no
it locked you you were you almost
killed me
he almost killed me
that was almost perfect it was not
almost perfect what do you mean
it was almost perfect i'm gonna change
out
for like i wanna see if the sound thing
is like super powerful goddamn
no stop being happy about what just
happened that was nice
i see the ghost the ghost is on the
camera right now it's okay axe
oh camera oh [ __ ] oh my god we need to
figure out where camera 13
is okay uh it'll say what the camera's
on up here
it's this one oh wow second story that
room so it is bottom right but it's
second story
okay so it'll be the back right yeah so
it's bottom left that's so weird
whenever activity spiked you guys were
on the right side are you going back in
mark
wait do you want tag in i'll go in you
guys need to both take like
two like uphill at least a bottle of
pills each this big flashlight is the
good flashlight right
yeah the bottom flashlight the bottom
flashlight the bottom flashlight the
bottom
yeah that's a good flashlight yeah oh
i'm an idiot i've been taking the bad
flashlight forever
okay what do you guys want me to bring
in what who's going with me
i'm going in uh well i had the third one
what do you have so you might want that
the microphone
we can't have the thermometer and the
thing
okay i'll grab the thermometer and a
motion sensor then okay
big daddy in the truck back online my
kitties how you doing today
uh doing better well doing well actually
i guess
fine i'll embrace uh lumpa 2 in the
truck
how you doing there uh willie's really
long legs daddy
doing great don't grade activity is at
two
my sweet sweet babies great thank you
look i oh wait can you talk with me
i just got an eight on this thing but i
don't know what the top and bottom of it
i don't know if it's detecting you
talking or not sure weird oh
oh my god oh my god oh my god
[Music]
you